The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So hello.
Today I want to talk about, and
I want to finish talking
about, search algorithms.
So last time we started to think
about a framework within
which to think about search and
the important thing was to
figure out a way to be
systematic about it.
So we figured out a way to
organize the way we think
about searching by
way of a tree.
Put all the possible places
where we could be in the
search, consider all the
possible actions that we could
take, so if we started it at
A, there are two different
actions we could've taken, we
could have gone to B or D
Think of the actions as the
edges of the graph and then
think about where we land.
Then, by way of that graph,
think about the shortest path
to the goal.
So that was the idea and the big
outcome was order matters.
So if we were to construct an
agenda, which is the list of
nodes that we are currently
considering, if we started at
A, we would start by putting
A on the agenda.
Then we would pop A out of the
agenda and replace it with its
children, its children
are AB and AD.
If the algorithm was replaced,
the first node in the agenda
by the children, the
first node is AB.
So then we would pop AB and
replace it with its children,
AB has children ACE, etc.
And the result would be
something that we call a depth
first search, because what's
happening is we're following
line lines deeply before
we look crosswise.
And there's a million varieties
of this that you
could think of.
You would get the same kind of
algorithm if you replaced the
last node by its children.
Then you would start with A,
replace it by its children,
which is still B,D --
but now expand D in terms
of its children.
Then you'd take the last trial,
expand it and we would
get another depth search.
So the idea is whatever order
you choose affects the
solution that you find.
Generally, we're interested in
finding a search that locates
the best, shortest path, and so
a good method is to remove
the first node from the
agenda and add the
children to the end.
That's a cube-based ordering
where the first out
is the first in.
Then if you imagine starting
at A, replacing it by its
children, B,D, take the first
guy out-- that's AB--
consider its children and put
them at the end of the list.
Then we go back and expand AD
before we think about the
children of AB and so the
result-- if you just follow
the red up here--
the result of that search is
what we call breadth first.
So we systematically propagate
down the search tree looking
at short paths first.
So that's the idea, the idea
is search is easy, you
organize it around one of
these graphs and just
systematically run through the
search by keeping track of
what we call the agenda, the
nodes under consideration, and
the only trick is that
order matters.
We found two useful orders last
time, first in, first out
and last in, first out, one of
those giving depth first,
which is generally
not a good idea.
The other giving breadth first,
which is generally a
much better idea.
Today what I want to do is
generalize that structure to
take into account a much more
flexible group of problems.
That'll give rise to something
we call uniform cost search
and the other thing that
I want to think about
is, again, the order.
By thinking about the order, we
can drastically improve the
efficiency of a search and
that idea gives rise to
something that we'll
call heuristics.
So the idea then that I want to
look at first in terms of
uniform cost search is the idea
that so far, we've only
looked at problems where
the cost of each
child is the same.
We were only looking at how many
children in total, how
many generations did we have to
go through to get from the
starting point to the goal.
That's an important class of
problems, but it's by no means
the only important class of
problems and in fact, the most
trivial problems you can think
of don't fall into that class.
So for example, imagine that
what we were doing, so I
motivated the entire problem
last time in terms of
searching for a path on
a Manhattan Grid.
So if I wanted to go from A to
I, where all the distances are
equal, then minimizing the
number of generations,
minimizing the number of
intersections that I go
through, will give rise
to the best search.
However, imagine that
one particular node
is way off the map.
Then the number of generations
that I go through is obviously
not the right answer because
there's a penalty for taking a
path that goes through C because
the distance between B
and C is so much bigger than
the distance, for example,
from D to G.
So the first thing that I want
to look at is how do we
incorporate that kind
of new information
into the search algorithm?
So before I do that,
think about how the
breadth-first search--
the thing we found last time
that was the best--
breadth-first search with
dynamic programming --
think about how it would
approach the problem and think
about as we go through step by
step, what is it doing wrong?
OK?
So I'm going to go through
an algorithm that is
known not to work --
with the idea that you're
supposed to identify as I'm
doing that what step
was wrong.
So imagine that I'm doing this
and then I'm going to compare
it in a moment to C
being off the map.
So if I do this problem with
dynamic programming, I have to
keep track of how many nodes I
already visited and I have to
keep track of all the nodes
under consideration.
The nodes under consideration is
what we call the agenda and
I will call the list of nodes
that we're keeping track of
for dynamic programming, I'll
call that the visited list
because we'll add nodes
to the list.
We'll add states to the
list as we visit them.
So we start out the algorithm
with node A being on the
agenda, we're trying to go to
node I. And by the time I've
started, I've already visited
A. So the starting point is
that the visited list has one
element in at A, the agenda
has one element in it, A. So the
algorithm is going to be
pop the first guy out of the
agenda and add the children to
the end, paying attention
to the visited list.
So pop A out of the agenda, the
children of A are B and D.
As I visit them, they get added
to visited list, B and
D. So I pop the first person
out, that's AB.
Then I want to think about the
children of AB, that's ACE.
A is already visited, so I don't
need to add that again,
but C and E are not, so I add
them and add them to the
visited last.
Then I pop AD out, well
the children are AEG.
A and E are in the list already,
G is not, so I end up
adding G to the list.
Next is to pop out C. The
children of C are B and F. B
was in the list, F was not
so I add the trial that
has F at the end.
Then the next one is E.
E has children BDFH.
B,D,F, the only new one is H,
then G. Take G out, the
children of G are D and H but
they're already in a visited
list, so I don't need
to worry about them.
Then A,B,C,F, so F is this guy,
C,E,I. CE I is not in the
list, and that's my answer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
once more, then you get
another path that's
equally short.
So why is that not the
correct answer?
PROFESSOR: A slightly different
algorithm might give
me that solution.
All that I'm tracing here, I'm
trying to be consistent with
the algorithm that we
discussed last time.
But that's a very good point.
So the breadth-first search with
dynamic programming is
guaranteed to give
you a solution
that has minimum length.
It's not guaranteed to give you
a particular solution of
minimum length.
So when there exists multiple
solutions with the same
length, this search algorithm
might to give you any of them,
and that's an important
thing to keep in mind.
So with regard to the problem,
I'm trying to think ahead.
I'm trying to think ahead to
where this C is off the map,
it's over here someplace.
So what I want to do is stop
thinking about how many hops
there were and start
thinking about how
many miles there are.
The first thing I want you to
notice is that this search
pattern that we did created
a visitation list.
We visited the states
in the order of
increasing number of hops.
That's obviously a good thing.
If we can always keep in the
agenda the smallest number of
hops to the next place, and if
we faithfully visit states
starting at the minimum number
and proceeding up, so we
started with A, there's
no hops in getting to
A, so that's 0.
In going from A to
B, there's 1 hop.
D there's 1 hop.
In going from A to B to C,
ABC, there's 2 hops.
So what the algorithm that
we described last time--
breadth-first with than dynamic
programming does--
is it visits the states
in the order of
increasing number of hops.
That's obviously a good thing.
OK so what's my next slide?
I want to think about
C being off the map.
So what I'd like to do is think
about what order would
this algorithm visit
number of miles?
So If I think about replacing
the metric in the bottom with
the number of miles, whenever
the different actions that can
occur incur different costs.
Think about what I'm saying.
So I'm saying that if I were
at B and I think about my
children ACE, which action I
take, go from B to A or go
from B to C are go from B to A,
which action I take incurs
different cost.
So what I want to do now is
think about, change the focus
from thinking about how many
hops is it to thinking about
how many miles is it.
So now, if I replace
the metric--
so over here, the metric was
how many hops, replace how
many hops with how
many miles--
and what you see is that the
algorithm is not picking up.
It's not visiting the
states in order of
increasing path length.
That's what's wrong.
So what we'd like to do is
modify the algorithm somehow
so that it proceeds through the
paths shortest to longest.
So that's the goal.
And that's pretty easy to do.
The first thing we have to do
is put that new information
somewhere, and I've already
alluded to the fact that the
way to think about the new
information is that it's
associated with actions.
It's not associated
with states.
States are where we go to in the
diagram, like state E. The
extra cost is not summarized in
the state, the extra cost
is summarized in the exact
path that we took.
And the way we'll think about
that is incrementally.
So we create the past by doing
actions and each action has a
different cost.
So the first thing we do is
associate this additional cost
with the actions.
Then we are looking for a search
procedure that will
enumerate the paths in the
order of path cost.
And the way to do that is to
think about the basic ordering
schemes that we had before,
which were the stack, last in,
first out versus the queue,
first in, first out.
What we'll do is we'll make a
trivial modification to the
idea of a queue and we'll call
it a priority queue.
So a priority queue is basically
like a queue, except
the things that are queued
have priorities.
So the idea will be that when
you push at possible action,
say I had actions A,B, or C --
in addition to pushing them onto
the queue, which is how
we would have done breadth-first
search, in
addition to pushing them on the
queue, I'll also associate
with them a cost.
So when I push A on the queue,
the priority queue, I'll
associate with that a cost,
which I've arbitrarily said
here, the cost is 3.
When I push B, I'll associate
a cost 6.
When I push C, I'll associate a
cost 1 so that when I do the
first pop, what will come out
will be the element that I
pushed that has the smallest
associated cost.
That'll be a way that I can
order then my search through
the search tree in terms
of the minimum costs.
Is that clear?
So the first time I do a pop,
the element that pops out is
the one with the least cost,
which is this one, so I get C.
C is then removed from the list
and the second time I do
it, when I do a pop, I pick out
the one with the cost 3
which is A. That's an easy
modification to the schemes
that we used before.
Just like before, we can
implement a priority queue
with a list.
Here we've put all the
complication into popping.
So we just push like we did
before, just jam it in.
So just add it to the
end of the list.
And we put the complication into
pop, pop looks through
the list and finds the
one that has the
biggest negative cost.
That's just because we've got a
utility routine that gave us
the biggest.
We want the smallest.
We know that the costs are
non-negative, so we implement
the find the smallest by calling
the routine find the
biggest with a negative cost.
So notice that all the new
complication is in this pop
routine, and if you think
about it, pop is doing
far too much work.
The way this routine works,
every time you do a pop, it
goes through the whole
list looking for
something that is small.
Obviously it ought to be able to
keep track of progress that
it's made in that previously.
There are much better
algorithms, but for the
purpose of this illustration,
we didn't bother with it.
So this is not a very clever
implementation.
We're not trying to be clever,
we're trying to
illustrate the point.
So if you were seriously try to
do a big search, if you're
writing code for Google, you
would never do it this way.
But the idea again is
in abstraction.
We're going to bury those
details in the way the queue
is implemented and then at the
next higher level, we don't
need to worry about
those details.
We'll abstract them away.
Is that all clear?
OK.
So this then is the way we
end up doing the search.
So when we do the search, when
we create a new node, the idea
is going to be that we
can generate a cost.
Remember, nodes in the search
tree summarize paths.
Nodes are different from
states, right?
States are places that we can
visit, nodes are paths.
So the thing that we need to
keep track of now in addition
to what we did before, before we
had the idea that nodes had
states, they have a place
where you are
currently in the search.
They have actions, which is
which direction do you go next
and they have parents and that
was enough information to
create and maintain
a search tree.
Now what we need to do is
also keep track of cost.
So we do that by adding
instantiation time.
When we create a new node, we
have to also pass it what is
the action cost.
So in the previous example, the
action cost would be the
distance from B to C, for
example, being 5, which is
different from the distance
between B to E, which is 1.
So we have to associate at the
time we create a node, what is
the action cost associated
with this new node.
And then the node keeps track
of the total path cost, so
that's what the red
stuff is doing.
So it's a very small change to
the code that we used for
creating nodes in the previous
two searches, and then we have
to also change the way we do
the basic search algorithm.
And here too, the idea
is pretty simple.
It's almost exactly the same
thing that we did before, with
the idea that we substitute keep
track of the agenda with
a priority queue rather than
with a queue or a stack.
There's one more complication,
and that is that in the past,
we knew that all children
added the same penalty.
Because we only keeping track
all of how many generations,
how many hops are there to the
current node, all children
were in some sense created equal
because we knew they all
incurred one more hop.
Here, because the children can
have different associated
action costs, we don't know at
the time we've picked up the
parent, we don't know at that
time which child is going to
end up being the shortest one.
So previously, the goal test
was performed when the
children were pushed
onto the agenda.
Here we have to wait until we
look at all of the children
before we will know which child
has the shortest length.
And that just means that we take
the goal test, which had
been inside the 'for
a in actions' loop.
We have to factor that out and
defer until the next time.
So that's the only change
to the algorithm
that we need to make.
So is that clear?
So the idea is it's a pretty
simple modification of the
algorithm that we have so far,
but it gives rise to a much
more versatile kind of search.
So last time we saw that there
was really no good point for
not doing the search, the
breadth-first search with
dynamic programming, we have
the same thing here.
So when you're doing the uniform
costs search, there's
no real good reason for not
implementing that with dynamic
programming, so we also want
to think about the dynamic
programming algorithm.
So you remember in breadth-first
search and in
depth-first search, dynamic
programming referred to the
principle that the shortest path
from X to Z through Y, so
if you have a path from X to Z
and you know it goes through
Y, the shortest way you can get
from X to Z through Y is
to add the shortest path from
X to Y to the shortest path
from Y to Z.
Sounds trivial, but it has a
tremendous impact on the
number of states that can be
omitted from the search.
Here, when we do the uniform
cost search, we can do the
same sort of thing but except
that we run into the same sort
of problem with not all
paths from X to
Y are created equally.
We don't want to remember any
random path from X to Y, we
want to remember the best one,
which means that in general,
we're going to have to expand
all of the children before
we'll know which child gives
the minimum length path.
So that means that the dynamic
programming principle that
we'll use is to remember the
state when it gets expanded,
because it only gets expanded
after its already being
compared to its siblings.
So wait until a state, wait
until a path has been compared
to all the siblings of that
particular path before you
consider it for dynamic
programming.
So we'll do that by not keeping
track of states as
they are visited, but instead
keeping track of states as
they are expanded.
That's the same idea that we
had to do when we had to
reorder goal test.
Defer the goal task until
after you think
about all the children.
Defer putting it in the dynamic
programming list until
after you've looked at all the
children and so that means
that we think about expansions
instead of visits.
And so that looks like this.
So just like we took the goal
test outside the action list,
in the previous breadth-first
search we did the test goal
state in this loop, here we
defer it until we've looked at
all the children and
fetched the parent.
So we defer it into the higher
loop, we take it out of this
moving into this and similarly,
we take the dynamic
programming memory.
We now call it expanded to
remind ourselves that what
we're doing is keeping track
of states after they were
expanded, not after
they were visited.
And updating it again, not when
we look at the individual
actions, but only after
we've decided which
trial is the winner.
OK?
That's probably confusing.
That's not important at this
point, because I've written an
example and hopefully by
thinking through the example,
you'll be able to see what the
code is supposed to be doing.
And then a good exercise is to
go through the example, which
will be posted on the web with
all the gory details, and make
sure that you can match
up the search--
the partial results of the
search-- to the way the
algorithm is written.
OK?
So now I want to do the
problem of interest.
Think about what if one of
these nodes, one of the
states, state C,
is very distant
relative to all the rest.
How will the new search, the
uniform cost search, work with
this problem?
So we do the same sort of
thing we did before.
Now we have an agenda to keep
track of the nodes under
consideration.
We have a dynamic programming
list that is going to be
called expanded because we
don't add to it until we
expand states.
It had previously been
called visited.
And we also keep track
of the metric,
which is the path costs.
So if we start by putting node A
on the agenda, its path cost
is 0, because it doesn't cost
anything to get there because
that's where we started.
And we haven't expanded
anybody yet.
So notice that the starting
state is a little bit
different here because we're
keeping track of expanded.
The expanded list started out
with 0 elements in it.
Previously where we were keeping
track of visits, it
started out knowing already
what was going on with A.
So now we expand A, think about
A's children, B and D,
put them on the agenda, and add
A to the expanded list.
We expanded A so it's time
to add it to the dynamic
programming list.
Then also keep track of the
costs of these paths.
AB costs 1, AD costs 1.
That's the end of
the first pass.
Now pop the first guy
off the queue.
Expand it, that means we're
expanding the B state.
We go from A to B, so we're
going to expand B. B Has
children A, C and E. A has
already been expanded so we
don't need to think
about A anymore.
C and E, so it was A, C and
E, C and E have not been
expanded, so I expand B to get
these two and I associate
their total path costs.
So the path ABC, ABC has
length 6 and the path
ABE has length 2.
Then I take the first one off
the agenda again, that's AD.
I expand AD, which is expanding
D. Put that on the
expanded list, on the dynamic
programming was list.
D has children A, E, G. A is
already on the expanded list,
so that means I have to worry
about E and G. Those paths
have length 2 and 2.
That was the same so far
as the previous search.
Now I see something different.
Because I'm using a priority
queue, I skip ABC because
that's just not the right
one to do next.
So ABC, I'm keeping track of
with the priority queue.
I know that that path
is already length 6.
It could end up being the
optimum path, but at this
phase of the search,
it's not the one I
should think of next.
The one I should think of next
is the shortest path.
So what I'm trying to do is
search the search tree in
order of shortest path.
So I skip the ABC because its
path is long and the minimum
length, so back up one.
So in the priority queue idea,
I want to extract from the
queue the first item with the
minimum length, so that's ABE.
Everyone's with that?
So then I want to expand E. E
has children B, D, F, H. So B
and D are here, F and
H are not, so I add
ABEFH to the agenda.
Each of those have length 3.
So what's the next guy
out of the agenda?
AUDIENCE: A and E.
PROFESSOR: I need the first one
with the smallest path,
the smallest cost possible.
The smallest cost possible is
2, so ADE is the next guy.
So I expand ADE, but I've
already expanded E. I Don't
need to do anything.
OK?
The dynamic expansion list is
keeping track of the nodes
I've already expanded.
I already did E, there's nothing
new to be learned.
So that doesn't do anything.
So the next one is G. Well I
didn't do G yet, so add it to
the expanded list.
G is shorter than D and H. D was
already there, H was not,
so add H.
The next one is F. I haven't
expanded F yet, so let's do F.
So F's children are C, E, I. C
is not there, E is there, I is
not there, so I add those.
So next is this guy, H. H
wasn't expended, so I
add H to the list.
H's children are E, G, I. EG are
already there, I is not,
so I add that.
Try expanding H, but already
did expand H so
that doesn't count.
Try expanding C, that's fine.
Expand C, I haven't expanded C
before, add it to the list.
C's children are B and F. B and
F are both there, didn't
add any new children.
AUDIENCE: Why'd you expand
that C, why not H?
PROFESSOR: Oh look at
that, you're right.
Oh, thank you very much.
My slide is wrong.
Ignore that, you're absolutely
correct, thank you.
So let's say I guess this
proves that 200 people
watching the lecturer have
greater insight--
well anyway.
Yes, that's wrong.
Don't bother with that because
it's got the wrong priority.
Jump straight to that.
I'll fix the slide on the web.
You're absolutely right.
I should have gone straight to
there and when I tried to
expand I, I realize that that's
my answer, so I'm done.
OK?
Questions?
OK it's a little tedious.
The point is that it really
wasn't very much different
from doing breadth-first
search.
The same ideas still work.
The same idea of organizing the
search on a tree, looking
for the minimum cost
answer on a tree,
that's the big picture.
That's what we want
you to know about.
I mean, we may ask you a quiz
question about breadth-first
search or depth-first search
or dynamic programming or
whatever, but the big picture,
the thing we really want you
to know is how to think
about a search.
The way to think about a search
is a sequence of states
organized in a tree
that you can then
systematically search.
That's the idea, and the point
of going through the uniform
cost search is to see first and
foremost, that it fits the
same structure, it's the
same kind of problem.
Secondly, there are very tiny
details and so I've tried go
over those details.
The details have to do with
keeping track of the action
cost and keeping track of which
one to do next by way of
a priority queue.
But the big picture is
the same idea works.
States, nodes, trees,
search, cues.
Questions?
Comments?
OK.
The other important thing that
I want to talk about today is
again, this idea of trying
to minimize the
length of your search.
The other point that you're
supposed to get from these two
lectures is depending on exactly
how you set up the
search, you can do a lot
of work or less work.
And we're always interested to
do less, especially because if
you can do a lot less, you can
do a lot harder problem.
So the other thing I want to
talk about next is the idea
that our searches so far have
been starting state centric.
What do I mean by that?
Every search has a starting
state and a goal, and the
ordering of our searches so
far have been go to the
starting state, think of all
the steps you can make from
the starting state and just
keep widening your search
wider and wider and
wider until you
stumble onto the goal.
OK, can you all see that that's
what we've been doing?
So nowhere in our code was the
code aware of the goal other
than am I there yet?
So the search algorithm so
far has been start at the
beginning state, ask if I'm
there yet, try the closest
place I can go, am
I there yet?
Am I at the goal yet?
Try the next closest place I can
go from the start, am I at
the goal yet?
Try the next closest
place I can start
from, am I there yet?
Everything has been starting
state centric.
Obviously, that's wrong.
Somehow, when you do a search,
if you were asked to find the
shortest route through the
interstate highway system from
Kansas to Boston, there's a good
chance you wouldn't be
looking at Wyoming.
Everybody knows enough
geography to
do that one, right?
So the idea is that in the
searches we've done so far,
you would look at Wyoming
before you'd look at
Massachusetts.
OK?
That's stupid, right?
Everybody sort of see that?
So the searches we've done
so far have been
starting state centric.
So what I'd like to
do is think about
a way to undo that.
But again, to set things
up, let's think about
what I mean by that.
Let's imagine a search very much
like what we did before,
except let's go from E to I,
from Kansas to Boston, and I
guess it's Kansas
to Tallahassee,
but you get the idea.
So we start at E and
let's think about
how our search proceeds.
So if you start at E, think
about if we push E in the
agenda, so I'm doing the uniform
cost search with
dynamic programing.
I'm keeping track of the
expanded state as my dynamic
programming state.
I'm starting at E. The cost of
being at E is 0 because that's
where I started.
And now, I think about expanding
E. So E goes on the
expanded list.
I think about all the children
of E, the children are
B,D,F,H. All of those children
have distance 1, so when I
look among them to figure out
the next one that I should do,
I do the first guy, EB.
B's children are A and C, so I
take off EB from the beginning
of the agenda.
Start again, B. B's children
are A, C, E.
E is already expanded.
Push A and C. Pop D, D's
children are A, E, G push A
and G because E's
already there.
Expand F. F's children
are C, E, I. E is
already there, push CI.
Expand H. H's children are G,
I, E, G, I. E is already
there, push GI.
Expand A. A's children are B and
D. They're already there,
don't need to do anything.
Expand C. C's children are BF.
BF are there, I don't
need to do anything.
Expand A. BD are already
there, I
don't need to do anything.
Expand G. G's children are DH,
DH are both there, I don't
need to do anything.
Expand C. BF, BF nothing.
Expand I, I'm there.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Were you supposed
adding ACE?
PROFESSOR: Was I supposed
to be adding AC?
You add A when you expand it.
Ah, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
I'll fix this one, too.
So the question was when I
expanded A, when I did this
one for example, when I tried
to expand A, I should have
added it to the list here so
I don't try to do it again.
It wouldn't have affected the
outcome, but I should have
added it to that list.
Thank you.
Class --
2 Freeman --
0.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if you
didn't expand it?
I mean, do you consider it
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] you
should expand it?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry, I didn't
hear the question.
AUDIENCE: We didn't actually
expand it.
We considered expanding it,
but then we noticed that.
PROFESSOR: Correct, correct.
So what I really should do is go
back and read the code and
figure out what I should do.
What I'm trying to do
is emulate the code.
So your point is, it's a
technical definition about
whether I want to think about
whether I actually
expanded it or not.
If I don't add any children,
was it a real expansion?
And that's a question that is
determined by where was the if
statement in the code, and
frankly I don't remember.
It does not expand it, ah
I have the right answer.
AUDIENCE: It does expand it.
PROFESSOR: It does expand it.
So I have the wrong answer.
Class --
2 and a 1/2.
OK so the point of this is that
the search was symmetric
around E, even though
the goal is not.
OK?
And the question is, how could
we fix it so the search is not
symmetric around E --
the starting point.
How do I fix it so the search is
biased toward going toward
the answer?
And so the way we think about
this is with something we
called heuristics.
So if you think about the
searches we've been doing,
either breadth-first or
depth-first from last time
where we counted the number of
hops or today where we counted
the lengths of paths, each of
those considered what thing to
do next based on the path from
the starting point to the
point under consideration.
The idea of a heuristic is to
add something that informs the
search about how distance, how
much distance we're expecting
to add from the point under
consideration to the goal.
So the idea of the heuristic is
to put in the second part
of the path.
The problem with a heuristic
is that finding the second
part of the path is just as hard
as finding the first part
of the path, and it would be a
terrible idea to -- for every
point in the search tree run a
new search to find the best
answer from that point
to the goal --
because that would increase the
length of the search time
enormously.
So it's a bad idea.
So the problems are of equal
complexity, the problem of
getting from the start point to
the place of interest and
the problem of going from the
place of interest to the goal
are problems of equal
complexity.
We don't want to try to solve
the problem of making the
search better informed by
increasing the complexity of
the search drastically.
So that's the issue.
So a heuristic is going to be
a way of approximating the
amount of work we have to do
yet, where what we would like
it to be is not all that
terribly difficult to compute.
So one way we could think
about that would be to
consider as an approximation
to how much work we have to
do, the Manhattan distance for
example, to complete the path.
The Manhattan distance is the
sum of the x and y distance.
Generally speaking, Manhattan
distance is not a good idea
for map-like problems because
generally you can cut across
corners in such searches.
In this particular search, since
I've excluded cutting
across diagonals, since the
search space is already
Manhattan, thinking about a
heuristic that's based on
Manhattan distance
is probably OK.
So the idea is to develop a
heuristic and he what I'm
going to think about is, what
if I complete the path by
adding the Manhattan distance
from the point under
consideration to the goal.
OK, so now if I started at E
like before and I'm going
toward I like before, then I
start with the agenda having
just E and having expanded
nothing.
However, the cost associated
with E is no longer 0.
The cost of going from E, the
starting point to E, the point
under consideration is still 0,
but I'm estimating the cost
of going from E to I by the
Manhattan distance between E
and I, which is 2.
The Manhattan distance between
E and I is you have to
increment x by 1 and you have
to document y by 1.
So instead of saying that the
cost of state E is 0, I'm
saying that it's 2.
Is that clear why
I'm doing that?
So now I expand E, I think about
the children B,D,F,H --
BDFH, and those children now
are not the same cost.
Even though it costs the same
amount to go from E to each of
its children, going from its
children to the goal, going
from each child to the goal does
not cost the same amount.
If I were to go from E to
B, that's a cost of 1.
But the Manhattan distance
from B to I is 3.
So I'm estimating, then, that
the cost of making the
decision go from E to B is 4.
The real cost of going from E
to B plus the estimated cost
of going from B to I. Similarly,
if I go from E to
D, the Manhattan distance is
3, so that's a length 4.
If I go from E to F, Manhattan
distance from F to I is just
1, so the total cost
is just 2.
So now rather than circling out
from the starting point,
my next step is biased
toward the goal.
So my next step is biased toward
so the remaining items,
the smallest cost is 2,
so the next place
that I expand is EF.
F's children are C, E, I.
E is already here, so I
only think of CI.
C and I also have different
costs, So the cost of going
EFC, EFC, the direct cost is 2
and the estimated distance,
the Manhattan distance between C
and I is also 2, so that's a
cost 4 whereas the cost of EFI,
EFI has a direct cost of
2 and the Manhattan distance
from I to I is 0.
So now I look for the minimum
distance that's remaining, so
that's going to be H. I expand
H, the children are E, G, I.
So E is already here.
I think about GI.
Same sort of deal, some of them
are short, some of them
are long and as I proceed to
the search, I very quickly
find I without having ever
looked in the wrong direction,
or at least having
looked minimally
in the wrong direction.
Is that clear?
So the idea in a heuristic is to
add an estimate of how much
it will cost to complete the
path so that you bias the
search toward the goal.
Rather than making circles
that spiral out from the
starting point, make
the spirals
biased toward the goal.
And here's the way
you do that.
It's very easy.
All you do is every place we
would have looked at cost
before, add the heuristic
function.
So you have to add a heuristic
function, that's the part
that's hard.
The code, given the heuristic
function, is easy.
The really hard part is actually
figuring out what a
reasonable heuristic is.
The reason that's hard is that
you have to be careful not to
miss the solution.
So the heuristic function
can't be bigger than the
actual distance.
OK, why is that?
The agenda is trying to keep
track of all the possible
places that you could
look next.
If your heuristic function makes
the next step look too
big, it'll be taken out of the
agenda and never appear again,
and you'll never
find that path.
So when you're making a
heuristic function, you have
to be very careful not to ever
overestimate the distance from
where you are to the goal.
If you ever overestimate it,
then you can exclude forever
more, so think about the agenda
as a pruning operation.
We did this starting
last time.
When we think about pruning,
we pop off
things from the agenda.
We say --
don't ever need to look there,
don't need to look there.
We pruned it.
If you have a heuristic that it
is too big you can prune a
path that was the answer.
So you have to be careful
never to do that.
So it's asymmetrical.
If you were to put in a
heuristic that is too small,
that causes you to underestimate
the penalty of
going in the wrong direction.
So if you said, I'm trying to
go from Kansas to Boston and
you inadvertently said that
Wyoming really didn't cost
anything, then you would not
necessarily exclude the
correct answer, but you would
include and cause the search
to consider a necessary path.
So the idea is that you would
like the heuristic to be the
same as the real cost
or smaller.
You don't want to end up solving
another search problem
in order to calculate it,
because that will increase the
cost of doing the
search too much.
So you would like some number
that's easy to calculate that
has the guarantee that it will
always be less than or equal
to the actual cost, and that's
the art of doing a heuristic.
If you satisfy those, then that
previous algorithm that
we looked at, which is --
in the literature it's call
the A-Star Algorithm for
historical reasons.
That algorithm, if you obey
these rules for finding
admission an admissible
heuristic, if you find an
admissible heuristic, then the
A-Star search will be a lot
faster and still find a solution
with the same length.
OK, so now just to see if you're
following what I'm
saying, here's a question
to ask yourself.
Remember the tiles problem?
The tiles problem is the first
problem that I did last time.
The idea was, imagine
starting in this
configuration 12345678.
Move one tile at a time by
moving the tile into the free
spot, so I could move 8 to
the right or 6 down.
Keep doing that until you
perturb this configuration
into this configuration.
We saw last time that there are
a large number of states--
there's a third of a
million states--
so this is a big search problem,
even though it's
something you've almost
certainly
also solved as a child.
And in fact, my version, it
was the same as yours, I'm
sure, was a 4-by-4.
I did the 15 puzzle, not
the eight puzzle, but
it's the same idea.
So what I want to do is
consider heuristics.
Consider three heuristics.
Heuristic A is 0.
It always returns 0.
That's an easy heuristic
to calculate, right?
Heuristic B is sum the number
of tiles that are
in the wrong position.
What is heuristic B
for this state?
AUDIENCE: 8?
PROFESSOR: 8 -- there's 8 tiles
that are out of position.
So heuristic C is the sum of
the Manhattan Distances
required to move each title to
their respective locations and
then calculate two
partial sums.
Consider MI to be the number of
moves and the best solution
if you use heuristic I and EI
is the number of states that
are expanded while you're
doing the search.
If you use heuristic I,
which of the following
statements are true?
OK, take a minute, talk to your
neighbor, figure it out
which of these are true.
[CLASS TALKING]
PROFESSOR: OK so what's
the smallest
numbered correct answer?
The smallest numbered
correct answer.
Oh, come on.
Volunteer.
Explain it with your neighbor.
OK, very good.
The smallest numbered correct
answer is (1).
MA equals MB equals MC.
Why is that?
How can I prove that MA
equals MB equals MC.
What do I have to do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You'll have
to reach the
shortest possible solution.
PROFESSOR: So under what
conditions will they all reach
the same length solution?
AUDIENCE: They're all
doing backflips.
PROFESSOR: They're all
There's another condition.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That they're all
either exactly [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the heuristics,
all three heuristics have to
be admissible, which means
that they have to be
non-negative numbers.
To be admissible, a heuristic
has to be non-negative.
And it has to generate an answer
that's smaller than the
actual number of moves
necessary to
complete the path.
So we have to prove that these
are all admissible.
So, are they all non-negative?
Yes.
Are they all less than or
equal to the number?
So let's do that.
Let's first of all
get an answer.
So we'll do that after we
do the second part.
What's the second smallest
correct statement?
Let me see if I can
answer it, yes?
OK, the answer is 4.
So, how do you know that
EA is bigger than EB
is bigger than EC?
So the number of states expanded
has to do with the
size of the heuristic.
If the size of the heuristic is
0, that's the same as not
using a heuristic.
That will search all possible
states in a breadth-first
search fashion.
If the heuristic is anything
that's bigger, the number of
searches will go down.
What's the greater than or equal
to thing doing here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Number (3) is
technically also true, because
if (1) is true, then
(3) has to be true.
PROFESSOR: If the number
(3) is technically
the number M. [LAUGHTER]
OK, OK, OK.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, class, three plus.
Freeman, oh well.
Yes, you're right.
Yes, I agree.
Did you raise your
hand for (3)?
So (3) is technically the
second, yes that's right,
that's right.
OK so moving on.
Number (5) --
the same best solution
will result for all
the heuristics --
true or false?
Come on, things can only
go downhill for me.
So the same best solution will
result for all of the
heuristics?
How could it possibly
be false?
Right?
Didn't we already said MA was
equal to MB equals MC.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's the same amount
of moves, but maybe not
exactly the same solutions.
So if there are multiple
solutions of the same length,
the difference heuristics don't
have to give you the
same solution exactly.
They have to give you solutions
with the same length.
So what happens with the
heuristics is you perturb the
order of search.
If you perturb the order of
search, the only thing that is
proved is that you get a minimum
length solution, not
the same minimum length
solution.
This particular problem has lots
of solutions and so you
don't necessarily get the same
solution when you use
different heuristics, OK?
So the final point is that the
addition of the heuristics can
be extremely effective.
If you run this problem with
our search algorithm, you
always get solutions with
22 moves in them.
That's good because all the
heuristics were admissible so
you always get a right answer
-- a shortest answer.
But the number of visited and
expanded are drastically
different when you add
the heuristics.
So if you use here heuristic A,
which is equivalent to no
heuristic, you end up visiting
170,000 states to find this
answer, where if you used the
Manhattan distance to the
goal, the sum of the Manhattan
distances, you do a very small
fraction of that.
So the point is that this stuff
matters, especially when
you do a higher-dimension
search, which is all of the
searches that we'll will
be interested in.
So the idea is that the order
really does matter and with
that, I'll conclude with a
reminder that tomorrow evening
is the makeup/retake day
for Nano Quizzes.
Please come to the lab if
you'd like to make up or
retake the Nano Quiz.